welcome back everybody wow what a
musical intro thank you Sam for helping
me with that it's episode 184.
yeah wow wow wow how did we get here
what a long strange trip it's been yeah
um so yeah uh today we've got Nico hi
we've got Sam hi
and of course
what's your name again hi hi
Jordan now it's us yeah
um so guys
um
I mean there's a lot going on there's a
lot going on it was my birthday just the
other weekend I got a mandolin yeah and
boy oh boy is a mandolin fun to play hmm
just saying like a tiny guitar oh yeah
but even like playing a guitar I don't
know there's just something about it it
just fits like a glove when you play a
mandolin Mountain handling music yeah
man handle it yeah never thought about
that before whether you manhandle a
mandolin yeah do you feel like you're in
this the old Smokies when you play it
Sam oh yeah absolutely it's beautiful
yeah well I don't know there's something
special about it like the cords and the
the way the scales and strings are tuned
and oriented it's just like it's more a
more natural way to play melodies it's
it's really interesting yeah and it's an
up the tuning is an upside down guitar
well uh kind of like a violin
traditional it's like a violin yeah
which is also an upside down it's a bass
guitar it's a bass guitar backwards
but never thought of it that way or a
violin forwards
yeah or a violin forward
to this guy the standard tuning anyway
this is mine
um Sam you know for how many uh Tim's
trying to steal my Lacroix right now on
this WOW thieving hands
have mine
I looked at I was like is this open I
mean
if I took if I took a sip yeah no I
caught you before you did no here here
oh cheers okay
I chose to infuse my body with
adrenaline and what 420 taurine what is
yeah anyways good times
just tourist things huh how many metal
albums you've made Sam you sure could
start yourself a bluegrass band if you
wanted to now that's the point of with
bulk metal is that you get to do both at
the same time right you always yeah like
I already recorded it for the beginning
of a metal song and it works great
nice can I be can I be vulnerable and
ask a question
this is a safe space all right heck yeah
you better not cry yeah oh my gosh where
it is blue blue why is it bluegrass
nobody knows nobody knows it's the Blues
Blue Grass is any type of grass like a
blue cheese kind of thing yeah it wasn't
Bluegrass just fast Blues that's a
little peppier boy grass I would get an
adventure that Bluegrass is the type of
grass that you find in the south
oh I'm gonna I'm gonna go out on a limb
here I'm gonna look this up to verify
but Kentucky Bluegrass is a type of
grass actually
and I believe that bluegrass music
because it came West through the
Appalachians into Kentucky which is
where most of it was sort of found
originally
um
yeah actually they did kind of find it
um and then there was this guy
um
oh my God I can't remember
this is yeah
the Bluegrass boys
of course so Bill Monroe issues
important to Everyday People Bill Monroe
started the Bluegrass sound and then
there was another there was another guy
I'm blanking on his name right now but
he invented he invented the three pick
banjo the three picking banjo yeah
that's right isn't that where it's like
bluegrass
it's basically Mario
Kart is Bluegrass I never knew that's
cool yeah that is sick
uh Earl Scruggs okay so Earl Scruggs
Earl Scruggs yeah everyone knows and
loves this guys
musical history
let me just get my piece out about Earl
Scruggs okay okay
the banjo the banjo is very important to
Bluegrass and originally it was an it
was an African instrument and used to do
what's called the claw hammer style
playing where you kind of you pick at it
and then you slap it kind of like
rhythmically
and then Earl Scruggs like a lot he he
lost his finger or like broke his hand
when he was a kid and so he didn't he
couldn't do that so he just started
playing it with three fingers oh wow and
he invented like this totally new sound
with it
um anyway well that's where it comes
from of the things I expected to hear
when I sat down 10 minutes ago let me
get my my opinion out about Earl Scruggs
was not one of them you just never know
what's gonna happen you never know what
you're gonna find there in the mountains
and then they went into the mountains
and they did find these old songs that
people had been carry that they had
carried over from like Scotland and
Ireland and they you know turned him
into Bluegrass songs wow yeah now you
know well now I know I guess I asked the
question so no regrets
no regrets yeah
well not even likes kicking it off with
a little culture here there you go warm
things up here to ground us do you feel
like we're all dancing around the main
topic of this podcast oh yes we're
waiting we're waiting for somebody
what is that topic
because CGI a bad word guys oh shoot
okay CGI a bad word well is it
did this become a bad word yeah I don't
know it did
yeah
that somebody does something for real in
a movie you're like wow I would love to
see that yeah that's that's just how it
works when you hear someone says oh I
did it with CG in my movie you're not
like oh man I gotta see the CG you know
it's just it doesn't have the
attractiveness and then even I guess
more importantly it's like
unfortunately for every good the effect
shot there's you know a hundred bad ones
you know what I'm saying
yeah you know I think it's a tough
comparison let me reel it back
all right okay in the 50s all right
we're watching what is it Jason and the
Argonauts that cool skeleton scene pops
on
were people rolling their eyes or were
people like wow people are well
we would say people are like wow but
reality might be that a lot of people
are like whatever it's coming for kids
this is claymation yeah like I don't
give a [__] yeah that might be actually
what a lot of the reaction was now to be
fair
the only people that mattered were the
people that said wow this is cool yeah
yeah no one everyone forgot all the
negative stuff
these were very close to the same people
who ran out of the theater when it was
footage of a train yeah right so clearly
there was a clearly their numbskulls
this is this is pre-evolutionaries
leap in time I'm there yeah I'm just
thinking of like once again you're
seeing something which it's like
ultimately like what's the purpose of
visual effects it's to convince somebody
you know of something that's happening
in your story well not even convincing
just to tell the story it's it's it's
too it's just to tell a story you're
like look none of this is real they're
actors I mean granted they're real
people but they're pretending and so
just like they are pretending we are
going to add other pretend elements into
this and sometimes they are
well there's like they don't look real
but at least they play towards the story
I feel like there's visual effects
either try to not break the illusion AKA
make things look 100 real and their job
is to erase the boom microphone that
came into the shot or put this actress
face in a stunt person so that you know
they still look like the stunt person
we're not breaking the illusion so does
that visual effects side of things which
is kind of also like the magic trick
side of things and then you have the I
need to imply something in my story I
need to communicate something my story
that's not real I'm not worried about it
looking real like I just want to tell my
story like I need a castle in the
background and it's clearly going to be
a matte painting or a model or a CGI you
know Castle whatever it doesn't matter
my story needs to Castle I don't care if
it's scribbled by a child's hands like
but that's what my story needs there's
that side of visual effects which is
basically animation like so much of CGI
is actually just animation with a photo
real filter on it you know yeah
and Bali would use that a lot I mean I
think of RR is a great example you know
like we've talked about it like the
effects are definitely they're getting
better and better but they're still like
visibly visual effects but they don't
deter us from enjoying the story it's
just helping us tell the story like the
tiger scene or all the tiger scenes
really you know it's it's just a method
is it isn't it isn't it really just a
matter though that like there's no such
thing as bad VFX it's just bad movies
yeah like yeah there's an argument isn't
that really the thing you know where
like I don't know uh what is it like a
costume designer walks into a theater or
pops something on Netflix and they're
like ew those pants like you know oh I
can't believe they're wearing that you
know like oh this is so gross I wish I
had never seen this you know is is you
know it's like anyone can critique
things here but like ultimately when you
see a bad VFX shot you don't go haha
because like it's bad it's mostly the
context of the already bad movie that's
now serving you bad VFX shot so it's
funnier in the in the context of this
already you know train wreck yeah of a
film if you're trying to make VFX that
are supposed to be totally real because
you're trying to not break the illusion
then the moment you can tell it it's not
real you're you fail at the VFX there
just like if a if a magician is trying
to Palm a coin and you can just see the
coin go into his palm and they just he
screws up the sleight of hand like and
clearly he ruined the magic trick but
like
other times VFX can be wacky and wild
you can totally tell their VFX and yeah
it's like are you gonna say Star Wars
failed you know
watching with some shots and you're like
that that looks like that's fake
foreign
but there are times when it does try to
be real you know like Star Wars isn't
trying to make the lightsabers look fake
he's trying to make the lightsabers look
like real things yeah but you see like a
little Ewok guy and you're like this is
a guy in a costume yes and you're like
this this movie sucks but here's I mean
did people just replace CGI with the
natural struggle of trying to portray
non-real things on film like yeah I
think so if we're if we're having this
podcast in the 80s on tape decks with
our like old-fashioned microphones we'd
be talking about how like man the new
costume work just sucks it was better
when they did costumes like this you
could totally tell it's like more real
or when they didn't have costumes they
just had to like fire weird looking
people or all the puppet guys going like
these puppets suck like like I did the
puppets on Star Wars and I'm watching uh
like I don't know the new guys who are
doing the puppets on Willow boo
you know like look at these Lamers yeah
yeah I don't know that you're that's I
think that's that's what it feels like
it's really just like I don't know it's
it's like the the language and the way
people communicate about criticism is so
I don't know it's more widely available
I guess now with just internet culture
in general although I don't know what
did people saying when Star Wars The
Phantom Menace came out
CG city right well I mean we we loved it
because we were like all 12 but yeah
yeah I don't know I didn't give a
question
you're right that's something I do not
remember the phantom menace coming out
maybe I was too young well yeah 1998 99
99 98. oh that was a wheelad okay no I
was waiting
I was uh small boy
I'm 32 now yeah so yeah you would have
you would have been like under 10. yeah
sub ten you're just you're an infant
you're like eighth grade then so yeah
you would have been like yeah yeah yeah
yeah
I mean eight years
you know six or seven or whatever um
anyways uh yeah this is a little Beyond
it yeah you're right but that's pretty
normal I think that's the best point
we're 12 and it's a normal Phantom
Menace age yeah what's random Menace and
I was like this movie is sweet I saw it
in theaters four times oh wow I was like
really into it yeah
their eyes
and all the N64 games that came out
incredible right right shadow of the
Empire Pod racer this is what I think
really proves my point it's like are you
into it and are you enjoying this you
know so to speak like are you are you or
are you thinking about this this element
here I mean
I don't know let me pause it this
question oh boy new one a new angle are
we going to see a swing in cinema away
from CGI spectacle well we already have
physical Spectrum I mean well not on a
major level or anything like that but I
mean Christopher Nolan's a perfect
example never no this is kind of what
what started the whole thing but him you
know kind of proselytizing the fact that
there was no quote-unquote CGI used in
Oppenheimer right it's like that's a
point of pride which is weird and that's
what run me the wrong way in the first
place is it's kind of a weird insult
yeah it's the wrong point of Pride and
the reality is like we're we're talking
about visual effects right we're talking
about the department that catches more
hot potatoes on a production than anyone
else they catch all the hottest potatoes
right at the end just chucking hot
potatoes and then everyone blames the
person with the Hot Potato at the end of
the song it's like come on fresh out of
the boiler if you're John Woon you just
finished filming hard-boiled and you
look around you saw Star Wars you saw
all these composited explosions you're
like look all the explosions in our my
movie are just real explosions and I'm
proud of that yeah it's like
more power to you yeah like seriously if
once again doing something for real and
having it be awesome
is always an achievement you know what
I'm saying like someone writes a crate a
great book and you're like oh yeah well
I actually went out and did all those
things yeah
I guess I guess I just I just the the
Line in the Sand that I draw is I don't
blame
the visual effects
you know what I mean like because again
you're right you're totally right like
what was the explosion you guys showed
me when I when I when I was so proud to
show you the James Bond explosion oh
that one from blown away and then yeah
and then you blew me away with that one
like that's a mate like yes more of that
please the things that are feasible to
do in real life yes more of that please
but when it's to such a degree that
you're like no you know what I don't
want any CGI in my film even when you
need it for the Trinity explosion you
need it you can't do that with a yellow
gas bottle yeah you're right I think
James Bond and Oppenheimer even though I
haven't seen it but I think I'm still
allowed to criticize it
right
um
I've heard from everyone saying anything
saying it's underwhelming and so it's
like and he's like no CGI I'm I'm
Christopher Nolan pretty good we're not
in filmmaker
than me no practical no CGI no no CGI
would ruin my film yes
and some swirly liquid and uh and you
will believe I will use my magic to
believe you you will be believed you'll
be trapped in my mindscape where this is
actually a nuclear bomb yeah that's
that's the true magic that he weaves
yeah he spends two hours
trying to convince you that it's a
nuclear bomb at the end he's like look
at all these actors they believe it's
real yeah
[Laughter]
with some swirly liquid and dust you
will be you will have no choice but to
believe it is a nuclear bomb
yeah we've been joking that the only CGI
that was used on Oppenheimer Was the
removal of all the CGI artists during
from the credits yeah that was the short
we were gonna film but then we realized
this probably because of all the VFX
artists that were used to uh paint in
the dress on the naked scene yeah that
was fast yes so there's a nude scene you
know people are naked they have sex Etc
and then one country's like no no no you
must paint a dress
uh red shirt blue pants yeah so they
painted they painted clothes on to a
bunch of people you know whatever yeah
so
I think those artists got cut obviously
from like the releases where
I mean no spoilers here but there's
there's the bomb guys a shot of the yeah
but
it shows like the world from space and a
rolling cloud of fire basically wrapping
around it I'm like hold on a second
maybe I'm misremembering it but I don't
think you can shoot that practically you
know unless they're saying what or stop
it's it's compositing stock assets and
maybe they've got a globe
that's possible I mean I don't know
maybe he lit half the world on fire
because he got that kind of money baby I
want to see that shot that sounds like a
CGI show it sounded yeah and it looked
like one too
not in a bad way
but just like
I could be wrong I'm sure there's VFX in
the movie but CGI computer generated
imagery
compositing I guess legally falls out of
computer generated because it was caught
on camera and then composited if you're
if you as an audience member are making
these distinctions
you don't actually care if the cfx or
CGI in the movie you're just playing
games yeah right it's okay we can all
play games we can all have sports teams
we can all live in our Imaginary Land
but like it doesn't matter if you
generated something with CGI or with
compositing depending on the final
product you're going to in terms of you
know you're going to just judge the film
without even looking at VFX respect well
composing it's okay for me to watch
versus CGI it's not okay for me to watch
like no I mean don't get me wrong you
can get amazing results compositing
results that you can't get with CGI and
vice versa but just the blanket judge
something you know to be like well
compositing is only okay when I use
filmed elements like well whatever but
again I think it's like go ahead Jake
well you can finish your point because I
kind of have another like take on this
another angle once we watch this angle I
mean my my thinking and I this is just
from my perspective here but you know we
know the immense amount of Science and
Math that goes into building these
effects it's like incredible
achievements and Hyper technical there
is nothing there is nothing to tether
the average person to those things so
whereas we look at it and we go wow
masterfully done incredible the Layman
would go oh it's just CGI it's just to
see oh they didn't do it for real I I
can I can comprehend to some degree what
it would be like to be near a huge
explosion right and I can be in awe of
that oh my gosh they did that in real
life but I can't if I'm just an average
person understand I had a technical
achievement how do you think the VFX
supervisor of The Flash feels oh my gosh
dark and soul Twisted tormented all the
genius things he pulled the science
like there's so much visual effects in
that movie you know they're like he's a
who's like weaving this visual landscape
and these characters and clone shots and
then everyone's like the bfx suck yeah
you know like granted I was
[Laughter]
it was obviously you know it was you
know you start to deal with now like the
whole question of the effects in
relationship to you know the client
relationship thing of like okay Studios
bids things like this and you know I
don't know I feel like there's an angle
there that is also tainting the
conversation too yeah can I can I
actually put out like a personal thing
that's been on my mind for like a year
oh boy you've been thinking about saying
something for a year I'm just I'm just
about this but this hasn't been like a
thing that you make a video of but here
in the podcast I guess I can finally
talk about it but so vfxrs react we have
this show which is I guess like I guess
it's like the number one VFX criticism
show of the internet but
you know
when I talk about things as a normal
person I'm like that was good or that
sucked you know it doesn't mean it
sucked but it's just how people talk
about things at least some people talk
about things it sucked to watch it right
it's like you completely ignore how much
work goes in the entire reason why it
exists yeah you completely ignore how
much work goes into things and you just
kind of like that sucked like you know I
came out of Rogue one being like Rogue
one sucked you know but like you sit
there you look at like this masterful
filmmaking there's talented people like
when you step back and you look at it
like for real it doesn't suck there's so
many incredible things to respect but at
the same time Nico the guy who isn't on
YouTube and doesn't do vfxrs reacts you
just watches movies and he's just there
with the millions of other people
watching movies Nico the guy is like
Rogue one sucked right
and I've like I'm I've been having a
really hard time reconciling that now
with like
my like react personality and like what
we do on the show because like on one
hand I know how much work goes into
things but on the other hand you can't
deny the human truth of being like that
sucked you know tell me about it right
isn't that that's the worst thing you
know when you're filming an episode with
a guest and they show you an incredible
shot that they had worked on you're like
holy cow that is crazy you know and in
the back of your head you're like too
bad yeah
really really difficult because you know
there's yeah there's what you're it's
what you're saying it's like there's a
ton of energy and talent and effort that
goes into it I mean what's really tragic
when even still that gut reaction is
just like
so you're saying to the whole film or to
the effects let's get to the next clip
because this is a cringy movie you know
so in context of the movie okay Nico
let's work through this actually this is
good so what's the name of the show
vfxrs react so do you feel like in that
capacity you are then obligated instead
to wear that cap yes not the Nico I am
obligated and is probably responsible
for to constantly be reiterating
probably time it's probably producers
yeah one can never blame the VFX service
actually but how how is that a show
though you know at that point you're
just constantly like
it's not dissimilar from we just me and
my wife just got a place and it's not in
Ruins but it needs a full gut rehab so
when we have friends over we default to
this apology tour as we take people
through the place yeah and we're you
know they're just happy for us they're
like wow you have your own you know
Kitchen in unit washer dryer this down
the other and we're just going in a room
going so we're going to totally redo
this also I'm just explaining ourselves
sorry about this you know it's kind of
the same parallel where it's like you're
watching these things you just feel the
need to apologize yeah you know oh well
I didn't have enough time and I didn't
have this then but you're right at the
end of the day if it's just a critique
of the film itself is is it it's is it
uh it's did it work or did it not and
that was the question when we were
watching The Flash that was the that was
the whole flash thing too it's like
you're like oh my God like this is just
I can't tell if this is a bad movie or
if this is a bad VFX shot and like
eventually became clear it's a bad movie
you know and also they were bad VFX
shots but
you know but the thing is constantly
you're like oh yeah but if you probably
think about it like this is probably a
talented artist and it's the situation
and the studio with the budget and blah
blah but you know you get so sick of
saying that you're just like screw that
Nick even yeah Nick even said something
he's like okay guys you guys
compensated for explaining why this
might look bad gosh but it just at the
same time I guess now I'm realizing
there is a duality to this thing because
at the same time I feel an obligation to
never stop saying that right as a visual
fixers because what if that's the only
one that someone Tunes in to watch
are they then taking away that oh these
guys just sucked but here's the thing
here's the thing sometimes I think it's
a it's possible it's possible
to critique something not based on like
an individual like for instance one
person makes a painting and you go that
painting sucks obviously the person who
painted it is the person who is at fault
okay you know what I'm saying like sure
that's direct and you can't say oh but
you know they were very stressed that
night and they had too much wine
and the paint shop was closed the day
before they're trying to finish the
painting and they couldn't get the right
color you know it's like like that
doesn't matter here's a person making a
painting okay so that's the criticism
but then the moment you say that one
shot from The Flash sucked it's
obviously like maybe there was a
talented visual effects artist working
on it but it doesn't matter anymore
because I don't need to know that like
I'm just watching a shot and it sucks
you know this shot sucks and guess what
is it that one VFX artist fault maybe
maybe not it's it's kind of hard to tell
because also there's this like idiot
running Warner Brothers Who's basically
driving the DC franchise into the ground
you know
you know because or or maybe it's this
nice like even gradient where everyone
contributes a little [__] into this pot
and then it's like a Jacuzzi man it's
like a Jacuzzi at a hotel
jacuzzi where it's like a VFX artist
she's not getting paid enough and
doesn't care about the shot and then you
have like a script that's been mutilated
by like 20 writers and then you have a
person who's like slashing a budget to
try and get it out faster by a certain
release date is it Ezra Miller's fault
it's just
at the end of the day it doesn't matter
whose fault it was you know the shot
sucks yeah yeah because Sammy you know
what you introduced me to the concept of
No Excuses filmmaking no excuses
filmmaking no one cares how much money
you have or hadn't
no one cares how hard you worked or you
didn't no one cares about anything
except the final product it's like oh
wow cool music album it's like oh yeah I
just recorded it literally in one day
and you're like wow fun fact you know
fun fact versus the other guy who's like
yeah I recorded this in one day and
you're like I can tell you know it
sounds like [__] it's like it's no
longer a fun fact meaning yeah that fact
kind of kind of pointless you know yeah
and it doesn't change the quality
doesn't change the quality
you know we've been trying to be more
criticizing of our own work with that
mentality as well lately like well
that's I mean that's that's I feel like
that's the key to actually making stuff
good is to be able to be like you know
talking to Sam and Sam's like here's an
idea I'd be like ah it's not good or
even it sucks and then exam goes
whatever you're right what about this
you know it's like to be able to do that
is so important but also like to have
that realness with like your your media
like as we doubt as we dip our toes into
the fringes of this like the studio
system here and there so you like rubbed
shoulders with some of the people
working there I'm reminded of how
careful everybody has to be I'm like
talking about those products yeah and we
don't have to be careful about ourselves
at all the party worries if this way
this dialogue this internal dialogue
like be like ah whatever that sucked
like is that just is that just me taking
my years of reading YouTube comments on
our own videos and having to like take
that kind of criticism is that just
manifested itself and like you know am I
just propagating the hurt another
generation forwards or is this just how
we are as humans well you're not finding
the people and saying that sucked right
like you're leaving a movie theater and
going ah I didn't like it yeah you're
right like that's fine I think there's
nothing wrong with that yeah if I have
to individually speak to someone who
contributed to something that I thought
had sucked you know I'd probably be a
little more positive about it
right that's all you give them oh that's
that's not like I'm not yeah and polite
it's like hey oh you worked on Rogue one
it's like tell me hey Sam tell me
exactly what you were saying when you
walked out of the theater or guilmo Del
Toro he comes to meet me like Sam
I heard you saw shape of water with your
whole family what what is the first
thing you said when you walked out of
the theater you know
yeah oh yeah uh
yeah my mom loved it
you know like I'd be polite I mean the
movie sucked obviously
I didn't need to say it that was the
joke right I think I think you are you
right as a movie guard because you have
paid for the experience and you can
interpret that experience however you
want to yeah you know so if you think it
sucked it sucks it's fine because you
paid for that so unless you torrented it
then you can't say it sucked you have to
keep it to yourself and there's also
those people like it surprised me the
people that play like a thousand hours
in a video game they're like hmm this
game sucks Steam Reviews yeah blow my
mind yeah yeah literally a thousand
hours and like do not recommend no good
I was starting to think something was up
we used to get that kind of comment uh
at stress level zero on some games like
somebody would come in with that type of
comment played a thousand hours yeah
yeah dude why did you play a thousand
hours we were just making sure Jake
you're being thorough
went to the theater to watch the movie
eight times
yeah I mean
geez I think I mean it is like but this
is like kind of coming back to also like
a a bigger discussion about like human
interaction at the same time because you
know a shot or a film is like an
abstraction you know it's like literally
just like images
or or film or something it's moving it's
not it's not a person it's not like it's
a representation yeah it's it's and it's
a subjective abstraction representation
of something else and so it's like oh
that sucked but obviously if we're
working in the studio here it's like
okay well Jordan how many times have I
told you something you worked on has
sucked only a few right yeah that's
pretty low
no he's never told me no no but that's
what I'm saying I was like there's a
there's a dialogue you know it's like
it's not like
it's like if even if like you saw
something that I made or worked on that
needs Improvement or vice versa yeah you
don't just lead in with like that sucks
you know you just say something like
what's it with the eyebrows
there's something going on
yeah you know but yeah I think that's
that's that's the thing too it's like
there's that distinction between like
the talented people who will create
something and then the result too
yeah I know there's nothing like there's
also that that I have like because
there's there's respectful Nico who
lives in the system and can talk to
people and he's a professional
and then there's like bad boy internet
VFX artist Nico who's a YouTuber and has
no boss and doesn't take any [__] from
anybody
um which which by the way that Nico
thinks is a way tougher guy than he
actually is
um where's the other jackets off camera
guys
but but there's definitely like a the
emperor has no clothes thing that I feel
like we're the only ones one of the few
people positioned on YouTube that can be
the people be like hey wait that guy's
not wearing any clothes you guys are all
saying he's wearing cool clothes it's
not worth anything you know it's like
it's when people a lot of VFX shots are
like that a lot of movies are like that
where there's talk about how this is
Cutting Edge or like you know big PR
pushes about something looking a certain
way or being done a certain way you sit
down like no it doesn't it doesn't look
it didn't do anything new it did this
did it new like we're the only ones
sometimes I feel like that step out and
say that or it can even be comfortable
enough to say that about a big budget
film where it's like this shot was a
mistake this didn't work this was a
problem yeah they failed at this which
we can say it about our work all the
time reduce that about our work all the
time because I guess in a way we don't
have millions and millions and millions
of dollars at stake when you have
millions and millions of dollars at
stake you don't want anybody saying that
you failed you know but at the same time
true Artistry means you can say you
failed true Artistry means embracing
that and being open about your work and
it's like that's why the show works yeah
it's like if when the money's saying you
can't that's a good sign that you are
something's wrong when he's like well
there's too much money for me to say
this it's like okay well then you're not
speaking honestly right yeah I think
that's and that you know to your point
Jake that is the the power of the show
specifically the OG react episodes
because I saw a few comments here and
there about you know when we do have
guests it's like oh you should present
them with you know their worst work or
or work that they're not proud of and
may I I guess from an educational
perspective it would be kind of
interesting to know hey what went wrong
or what were the the you know the the
issues that arose during the but then
the question comes how much can they
really say and you like you said they're
so they have to be so careful because
again there's this interconnectedness in
the community that may cost them future
work so they don't have the freedom to
just speak openly like that and US
putting them in that position isn't
really fair in many ways so yeah it
would be great though to know but yeah
and once in a while we get somebody
through the the couch you know who who
has a position professionally where they
can speak like that like Tim Miller is a
great example yeah he's like whatever
I'll say whatever I want yeah and he's
just maintained that as his like modus
operandi forever so if you work with Tim
Miller that's what you're getting you
know
um and that's super cool when when we
have those kind of guests they're very
rare like this is It's hard to find
people like that in the industry not
because people are dishonest but because
somebody having that kind of
Independence is tricky to find yeah yeah
it's like that in almost any industry
you know there's this there's some
people who have done it at such a level
of accidents that they've risen to the
top and they can say and speak openly
about the condition of whatever their
product is but then there's a bunch of
people between them and the consumer of
that product
that are actually pushing the product
out that probably can't do that because
a it's
like like you said Jordan it might might
cost them work in the future but also B
it might not even be their place
necessarily to say that
um so you just hope that the few people
who are at the top of whatever given
thing it is are actually able to speak
honestly about it because that's that
actually helps the industry in the long
run
yeah what's what's like the what's the
worst VFX shot in a good movie you guys
can think of
like what's the what is their classic
one like oh that's that's bad I mean
there's there is one shot in particular
in Lord of the Rings I think it's
Fellowship of the rest getting on the
elephant oh getting on the elephant oh
oh you're that's uh return return to the
king yeah yeah that Fellowship but now
that mine is very minor mine is like not
visible very much unless you're looking
for it but it's when the camera flies up
past the statues the stuffy statues you
know I looked at that shot I couldn't
see any problems I gotta show you
because there's a bird's nest on its eye
or something it's one of the worst ice
so for bxrs react I was like I had heard
about this from you and I looked for it
and I looked for it and I looked for it
and I couldn't find it I gotta show you
I'm gonna show you off camera we're
recording an episode tomorrow
I already got my stuff radiator and
Gladiator there's a shot where the
tigers are attacking him they're not
that great but at the same time it was
2001 and they were doing full CG Tigers
jumping onto him
well he's in this fight and so
you know the rest of the movie's so damn
good that you just look right past it
well I mean even the way you guys say it
they say it's so like hesitantly I love
lord it's like they're cool pieces
they're cute they're cool movies yeah
and so like I still think that's really
what we're kind of still talking about
here which is oh it was really cool so
hey something didn't look totally real
doesn't matter I'm into it yeah like
it's it's not gonna like ruin the
experience yeah just because you can go
oh that's CGI yeah it was my 16th
viewing and I paused it I laughed at it
with my roommate for about 10 seconds
and then I continued to watch the rest
of the movie uh completely consumed by
the incredible stories yeah right yeah
you're totally right a shot did come to
mind remember Anakin Skywalker trying to
ride that one creature in the second
Star Wars prequel that's that's for yeah
because for me it's it's like Legolas
hopping on that ogre or whatever yeah
you know in two towers I think it is
it's like it's always that it's always a
character topping on another yeah
it's because they have like a cops first
and it was just like you know 2D tracked
yeah perfectly still yeah it just never
works I mean I think really the CG was
just coming back to like this like the
topic question though it's like I think
people's like idea of like bad CGI is
really just closely tied to like
soulless media ultimately you know where
it's like okay well I'm making a piece
and so I'm gonna decide what in the
piece I'm gonna try and do for real and
what is going to be CGI and very often
you get pieces that are just like oh
we'll just do it all it's all all CGI
you know and and it usually turns out
poorly and it's kind of like well it's
because
I don't know maybe you needed to handle
this idea with more care or something I
guess you know still The Flash versus
Man of Steel are great examples because
there's lots of moments in the flash
that they already did in Man of Steel
like same fighting techniques and visual
effects and styles and you like watch
both films and you're like okay that's
cool
that's well done and that one's not you
know and you're like well why is it like
they've already done it the same Studio
did this you know was it that hard to
replicate something that's already been
done and apparently it is and so the
only answer of why it wasn't as good as
the original is because
just someone didn't care enough about
making it and that's when you're like
okay this is soulless now like this this
is a sign not necessarily that it's fake
or that it's not real but it's like
someone didn't care that's how they felt
in flesh making this cool yeah he said
he was left feeling bad for liking it
like liking the character like he's
being made fun of like they took his
money and then they were just picking on
him by showing him the movie when when
you were doing a freelance Jordan
did you find yourself having to either a
fight to invest yourself in something
that you didn't want to be invested in
or be
fighting to not invest yourself into
something that you shouldn't be
investing yourself into because it's
just a job like when you have to
assassinate somebody it's just a job
or anything purely business uh yeah my
my freelance journey man like you know
it's a it's a meat grinder it really is
like to a certain degree and and you
know I had my experiences just a
freelance artist I had my experiences a
freelance supervisor and supervisor
artists on all these different jobs and
like
it really depends on the people you
surround yourself with like I learned
with some people it's best to just keep
the department separate like don't be
friends and also work for because a lot
of the times you can get taken advantage
of it in that way and then there are
some people that you can really trust
but what I started to find
on quite a few sets is there's this
General sense of
like misery or negativity which is it it
confounds me a little bit because at the
end of the day we are still making some
pretty cool stuff
um but in visual effects I mean unless
you're working with a post house that
will provide you some assistance to help
gather assets and whatnot on set you're
typically a department of one and
there's a freedom associated with that
because you kind of have the your you
know rule of the roost for that
department which is nice but at the same
time it you're the first it's the first
day of school every day and it's and at
a certain point I did feel myself start
to turn a corner into
oh no you know and and coming from where
I came from like I've always been quite
happy go lucky when it comes to this
stuff and always very excited to jump on
projects and whatnot but I was starting
to turn that corner and I you know as
luck would have it the day that Jake
reached out to me that I'd gotten uh I
guess I was a finalist for the position
here was
undeniably my worst day on set oh really
it was awful dude it was awful and I was
literally debating my future on set when
I got that that message and then I was
beaming the whole day I was like you
can't bring me down anymore you can't
stop me now misery um yeah so it's hard
it's a constant fight you have to like
and that's why I do so much study on my
own time because I I work to preserve
the spark of curiosity yeah apart from
that so I was becoming like you know
there was like a duality to what I was
doing
um because I I felt no sense of
ownership or or creativity in in the
client work side yeah I just you know I
feel like that aspect of project
leadership just gets really overlooked
when people talk about filmmaking and
being a good filmmaker it's like
apparently oh you could be a good
filmmaker if you're a good script like
if you do a bad job managing your team
or inspiring them as it's the producer's
fault it's like well that's like you're
saying it's almost just as important if
not more important than anything else to
have your team be inspired and like
happy to work on the art together to be
doing something together like that kind
of leadership
that's a real magic thing to have yeah
you can bring it to set and it's it's
driven heavily by the director very very
heavily by the director
um that shifts the tone of the set and
also if you know I did a lot of music
video stuff by the artist too and this
is my cue to say J Balvin is a gem of a
human being and uh I was doing a video
with him and I didn't really know him
very well it was arguably one of the
most hectic days on set of chaos and he
came in like this beam of light and was
just thanking everybody and so profusely
grateful and that is what I realized
drives me and I'm sure so many other
people like yes we do it for the money
so that we can pay the bills it's
crucial but man feeling appreciated that
is the spark that keeps people going on
sets like so so crucial
um to experience so I encourage any
directors out there make make your crew
feel appreciated it's very important
yeah and until the grips and Gaffers out
there you're the ones who actually
decide who's cool on set and we're all
really just trying to impress you guys
I'm just like please like me can I stay
with you at lunch is that cool
gosh darn it man also the way that they
light you they'll like they'll light you
bad if they don't like you yeah
um no so I have one more kind of like
turn in this conversation
um do you think that any of this uh I
guess like idea of CGI somehow being
this bad word is in any way related to
just how magnificently it has been done
in the last 15 years because
with the advance of computer technology
I mean we've seen
some incredible
use of visual effects like stunning
you'd show it to somebody 30 years ago
and they would not know how you did it
or where it came from or how it was done
and consumer like viewers just look at
it and go yeah that was cool you know
what's next but it's like guys do you
realize like that there's so many
examples but
you know they're they're like destroying
cities
in some of these you know marvel fights
and people just go yeah this is this is
what I came to see yeah this is it this
is it but
it's like there's there's how do they do
that CGI yeah yeah they did they did it
with CGI the buttons like
yeah the button I think it's just I
think it's the relationship to money
that's like throwing people off not that
like it's oh you want to make money
doing CGI but that like spectacle and
Blockbuster have become like such a big
part of this that it feels to me it
feels like modern Cinema mix up for a
lack of either commitment by the talent
or commitment by like the story writing
team or even the directing team they
make up for that lack of commitment with
visual effects it's like oh here's an
actor that you really like cool we had
him for a week all the rest of his
visual effects it's like no I want to
see that person perform I want to see
them sweat I want to see them cry and I
want to see them bleed I want them to be
on that project for at least eight
months like when I go to see something
that's like a million bajillion dollar
production that's like socially an earth
moving production I expect the main
talent to be there for more than two
weeks filming that thing you know and I
I get that vibe that VFX has kind of
become this thing that's like just
lifting everything else up on its
shoulders so that all these like you
know famous actors and the celebrities
and the star and like the you know the
advertising campaigns the merch deals
you know all that can actually sit up
there and it's like VFX and CGI that
lifts it up there you know that that's I
think what to me has like soured it for
me a little bit or at least made it that
bad word so to speak
it also doesn't help that you know a lot
of the times visual effects is supposed
to be invisible and so you miss all the
good like by Design you don't see any of
it and then what you catch you know yeah
yeah it's like oh you did a bad job
hiding oh you I caught all four of you
and it's like dude there's 300 of us
singular aspect of this too which is
just this is probably just very much a
me thing but like watching something be
like okay they put all the work in for
this I spent this much money for this
like and nothing solidifies that more
than Avatar and not just Avatar is not a
bad film but it's one of those things
where like it doesn't it doesn't feel
like the story of Avatar isn't really
any
as any on any higher level than any
other like decent summer blockbuster
movie and so when I can just read the
history of the Nez Pierce Native
American tribe if you wanna I mean sure
I mean look the story is a little janky
but no but the point is like you go in
it's like they put all of like all this
effort into this film it's like but is
there not if like if they have you know
teams of hundreds working for years to
do the VFX at Avatar why can't you have
a team
of maybe not hundreds but a team of
hundreds working for years to write the
story well you know I mean sure but like
if you pick a director in Hollywood that
uh could swing pulling that off though
no you're right it's like really just is
it James Cameron director of like
Titanic I mean that's the movie we get
yeah you know it's like I'm like this is
fine like yeah he I mean who else would
want it like Steven Spielberg it's like
we've seen what his CGI you know films
look like basically and it's like I'm
not saying the Avatar is a bad film it
just it feels feels odd to have so many
resources put into that one versus
others what what movie should have had
that treatment
good question yeah so that's like a
financial risk reward thing though
that's not a decision made a creative
level
risk for the project and and the studios
saying we're going to risk this much
because we think I mean the last one did
a billion dollars in like what a couple
weeks
so we're gonna risk we're gonna risk it
again true it's just if not Avatar then
what you know it's like another Jurassic
Park movie or Indiana Jones is that it
maybe I lost like 400 million no 200
million dollars in Indiana Jones oh did
they really yeah well it's because they
made a really bad one and then they
thought let's make one more
there's there's only been like three
films that made money this summer yeah
flash lost about 200 million as well
good good good yes yeah
it's the only way it really is the only
way yeah stop making car garbage yeah
it's it's I mean I've said this before
but it's the exact same parallel to the
pre-game order thing yeah it's like
cyberpunk is a perfect example everybody
poured their money into it and it was a
dud and there's so many other games like
that you pour your money in and it comes
out super buggy they don't care because
at the end of the day you already paid
for it it doesn't make a difference so
you know people are voting with their
money and we're seeing that with movies
is people are tired Marvel had an
amazing streak dude like leading to end
game that was so hype and that was so
fun okay it's done now it's done now but
no it's not here there's a whole new
slew of people nobody cares anymore it's
like but none of these superheroes are
even cool like all the ones you picked
like I remembered yeah and then it's
like here's all these ones here's like
this Marvel and I'm like what
to like harness this and that's not an
easy person to find it because
these companies by and large are you
know the structured like businesses and
so you
it requires that person to come in with
the new vision and go look Marvel good
job guys you did a great thing everyone
loved it
now we're gonna do this we're not going
to try to cop like ape your style and
and copy it we're gonna do something
totally different and yeah
it's not gonna be this
yeah SpongeBob Cinematic Universe dude
Mario Cinematic Universe coming soon
Barbie Cinema and it was it was zombies
before it was zombies and werewolves and
vampires before Marvel that's very true
actually yeah now it's superheroes it
was World War II before that by the way
it was World War II before that yeah
yeah yeah and then the 90s were just
like yes everyone's getting kidnapped
it's been a 90s movies were just like
yeah kidnapped my daughter 80s 80s was
just action heroes 80s was just like I'm
a cop but I don't act like one oh yeah
I'm bad I'm a bad cop bad I'm struggling
to keep my job I'm a cop I have to break
the rules to do what I think is right
yeah yeah basically yeah and before that
it was just a black and white good guy
bad guy situation
I'm excited you had the 70s and like the
weird abstraction you know like the 70s
like oh we forgot how to edit films Peak
action editing is 70. we're like we
forgot how to edit but there's boobs
yep yeah or no the 70s is also like yo
you guys ever think about what the
future is going to be like
[Laughter]
check out these wacky like bulbs and
these spheres people are gonna wear on
their heads and these wacky like red
jumpsuits
we're all just suggestions
yeah yeah so I don't know there'll be
another there'll be another thing but
hopefully it comes soon because it's uh
it's a desert out there boys it is man
oh yeah I'm just hoping we see uh and
now no one's making movies anymore
revitalization of the 90s era
entertaining films made for a budget
that matches the reach of the audience
and that's it there's no series being
milked for Time on Netflix there's no
stuff being made to fit a demographic
and fill a slate there's no movies being
made because they can make money
according to the bottom line there's
just I have a good idea for a show give
me a budget that matches the size of the
audience gotta go watch it let's make it
I'm just hoping those start happening
more and more and what yeah I want
Netflix to start using their damn
algorithm like yeah look at what I'm
watching and like all the closest people
around me like who watch similar things
and just Mash everything up you know I
watch Viking animes you know that's cool
I watch sci-fi shows like do a Sci-Fi
Viking anime thing you know like
whatever like just who cares just make
it happen like you have the data yeah
like come up force it to be original you
know just like play uh what is it what
are those games but you need an
executive at the top who's into Viking
anime sci-fi right see that's the thing
like it's just get the bucket of all my
like you know tags yeah like all the
metadata that we all have like just take
take a scoop and turn that into a strip
how hard can it be and you gotta make it
for a few bucks because Sam will watch
it I'll probably watch it too and
that'll be about the end of it yeah
oh that's where we're headed yeah
or serve me more properties that I love
please serve me please sir we're seeing
the dying breath of a master's favorite
properties and make cinematic universes
out of them yeah
all right good stuff dude did we just go
full circle though two with Hollywood
it's like it when's the point where like
everything's going to have been made
they're like guys
we've searched the last 3 000 years for
like franchises you don't need them all
you know what I keep hearing is the
constant return to
Hollywood is America's greatest import
and they're killing it it's like ah no
come on guys
we make a lot of other good things
besides Hollywood
you mean
greatest export
great sorry X I said export right
important you said it I'm a doofus it's
fear yeah
actually no no fear is the greatest
export yeah yeah actually I thought our
greatest export was uh Unreal Engine
five yeah
iPhones aren't bad either
iPhones who who is exporting iPhones
that's the question well we're exploding
the design
yeah it's not in America all right yeah
price the bill with five bucks yeah
press the design them five trillion yeah
right that's what matters
I'm not worried about Hollywood as an
export I think that's a-okay just make
your media make people yeah I think if
you do have a sustained period of
downturn uh I mean the strike honestly
is gonna work towards that uh For Better
or For Worse but also if you have a
sustained period of downturn on like
some of these big risks and these
Blockbuster risks that model will have
to go away and they'll have to turn to
more what you said like let's be
poignant and pick a budget for the size
of the audience that we think it's going
to reach and really just let creators do
their thing and
that's not the worst Universe to live in
no there'll be a lot of jobs there'd be
a ton of work there'd be a flourishing
creative industry so maybe that's what
will happen hopefully and we've seen I
mean we've seen that people are willing
to go to the theater still like Barbie
Oppenheimer like a lot of a lot a lot of
people showed up for that yeah I didn't
go to either of them because of the
spectacle yeah I haven't gone to
oppenheimer's I didn't even go for any
reason on that one yeah yeah but I
didn't go to Barbie to be like oh the
big CGI set pieces like you know yeah I
went to Barbie for the writing yeah yeah
the performances the quirky scenes and
performances of your favorite childhood
toys and Ryan Gosling hey Ryan got yeah
AKA just Ryan Gosling yeah Ryan Gosling
super hot
that's it we got Ryan Gosling he might
say four things and we got Margot Robbie
super hot
that's
all you need come on in
all right well hey that was a fun one
um I hope you enjoyed it out there
watching and listening and uh see on the
next one all right that's all everybody
so long sorry if I offended anyone no
you can't back down now don't apologize